DYLAN THOMAS: Hello, and
welcome to "What in the World."
This is a regular show where
Enterprise Googlers talk
about an interesting topic
for Maps or Business.
My name's Dylan Thomas.
I'm a Maps community
manager, and joining me today
is Avnish Bhatnagar, who's a
technical solutions engineer.
Hi, Avnish.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Hi, Dylan.
It's a pleasure
to be here today.
DYLAN THOMAS: Thanks.
So you're an expert on
Google Earth Enterprise.
And today you want to
show us a bit about what's
coming up in the 5.0 release.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: That's right.
We have a lot of
exciting new features.
We've listened to our customers
about many of the feature
requests that they've
asked for over the years.
And we're really
pleased to announce
that we implemented
many of them.
DYLAN THOMAS: So
I think today you
were going to talk about
the new publishing workflow.
You're going to talk about
alpha masking and WMS.
But I think first you wanted to
just say a few words about how
this release fits into the
broader picture of the product
plan, right?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: That's right.
Google Earth Enterprise
is an important component
of the overall ground
to cloud strategy
at Google, wherein you
could take layers that
may exist in Google
Earth Enterprise-- online
or offline in Google
Earth Enterprise.
You could cut those globes that
you have in those two platforms
and serve them all together
in a single unified way.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
So we're sort of removing the
boundary between the products,
in some sense, by letting you
take data from Maps Engine
and serve it with
Earth Enterprise,
or take data from Maps
Engine and serve it
with another product entirely,
like the portable, right?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly,
through the portable server,
that's sort of the
common denominator
that bridges Google Earth
Enterprise and Maps Engine.
DYLAN THOMAS: All
right, well, thanks
for sort of setting
the scene there.
So I guess, why don't we take
a look at some demos now?
I think you were going to
start with the new publishing
workflow.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Yeah.
So I have here my Fusion
machine that I've logged in to.
So as before, I just go
ahead and launch Fusion.
And this may look familiar--
not too many changes
on the front end of Fusion.
And these are some
databases, both 2D and 3D,
that I've already
built here in Fusion.
So if I start with the
3D one, for example,
this BlueMarble database, a
very simple BlueMarble database
with a few vector layers.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: If
I right click on this,
you'll note that the option for
push is there, but not publish.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
And the reason is,
is we've decoupled
Fusion and Server.
Publishing now is a
server-side function.
And that goes a long
way in simplifying
the overall workflow,
wherein before, you had to,
on your server, create what's
called these virtual servers.
A virtual server was essentially
one part Apache virtual server
and one part the
publisher mapping
that existed in Google
Earth Enterprise.
And to be honest, it's somewhat
complicated to properly create
that virtual server with
the Apache directives,
configure it.
And so that's vastly
simplified now.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: All you
need to know now in Fusion
is build your database and
push it to your server.
DYLAN THOMAS: Perfect.
So it's just way simpler, one
concept instead of a couple.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
So I've already
built my database,
so I'm going to go
ahead and push it.
When you say Push, I have
one server association
that's built out of
the box called Public.
And I select the version of
the database I want to push,
and I say Push.
It gives me the database
successfully pushed.
So now what I'm going to
do is go to my server.
And this is something that's
new in that there is now
an actual user interface, a
web-based UI for the server.
If I just type in
the URL of my server,
I'm presented with
a splash page that
confirms the version I have.
And at the top right is
a button that says Admin.
I click on that.
And typically, I'd be presented
with a username and password,
which in this case
has been saved.
But the idea is that
only administrators
should have access
to this admin page.
So this admin page, number
one, functions as a dashboard.
Tells me right off the bat
how many databases do I have,
how many of them are published,
what my disk storage is
like, what the cutter status is.
So in one unified view, I can
get a snapshot of my server.
DYLAN THOMAS: So in
a 4.x environment,
let's say the
current environment,
how do you get this
information right now?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Well, since
there was no single UI in 4.4,
you had to get this information
through the command line.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Various
command lines and-- yeah, you
would have to extract that
from different [INAUDIBLE].
DYLAN THOMAS: So [? in ?]
5.0, you can still do that.
We're not taking that away.
You can still get that
information in that way
if you've got scripts that
pull from it or what have you.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
DYLAN THOMAS: But this just
gives you a much easier option
to get everything in one shot.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Right.
It really, I think, facilitates
management of your server.
Under Settings, I
can also look at-- I
have direct links to
my documentation, which
is bundled with the product.
So it's not reaching
out to Google
to get the documentation.
It's in the product itself.
I have a link to my Apache logs.
Oftentimes, when
something goes wrong,
the first place you want
to look is in the logs.
So now we have a direct link to
the access log and error log.
And I can launch my
cutter from here.
In other words, if I want
to cut my 2D or 3D globe,
I can launch that as well,
directly from the UI.
But let's now go to Databases.
DYLAN THOMAS: Because we're
trying to publish, right?
We're trying to
finish the second part
of that process you started.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
So you might recall, I published
my BlueMarble database-- sorry,
I pushed it from
Fusion to my server.
So it's showing up right here.
There's an entry for
BlueMarble version 15.
And it shows that the status
is currently unpublished.
So all I have to do is
select it, click on Publish.
And here is where I
select a publish point.
This is what we used to call,
in the past, virtual servers,
where this part of
the publish point
is what defines
how users are going
to connect to your [INAUDIBLE].
DYLAN THOMAS: So
the endpoint access
they would use-- in their
client to connect to the server.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Right.
So I could call it
something simple, like demo.
I tell it what search tabs
I want in this database.
And note that I can mix and
match what types of search tabs
I want.
It's all specified right
here in this single box.
Snippets-- also something that
I no longer add in Fusion,
but I put in right here
when I'm publishing.
And the advantage of that is
I can have different snippet
profiles for different
publish points.
So that way if I
had a secure globe
and I only wanted
certain logos to appear
on that secure globe,
certain search tabs,
I can define that here.
Whereas if I wanted
a public globe that
has this same underlying data
but with different search
tabs and different snippets, I
can manage all that right here.
By default, there's only one
virtual host, which is public.
If I wanted to create
a new one like secure,
I could do that and add in
all my LDAP or authentication
credentials.
And here's where
I select whether I
want WMS enabled on
this globe or not.
So I say Yes.
DYLAN THOMAS: We're going
to get to that in a minute,
though, right?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
And then I click on Publish.
Done.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: At this
point, my endpoint is ready.
My globe is ready to be served.
If I click on that again, I
can even preview it right here
within the browser.
It's going to open up my--
basically, as you can see here,
the URL is basically that
of my GE server slash demo.
And in this case, it's trying
to load it in the plug-in.
As the plug-in loads,
I can also directly
connect from EC, the Enterprise
Client, which I'll launch here.
DYLAN THOMAS: So the
publishing process
is pretty much instantaneous?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
Because it's essentially
just a mount point.
And there's my globe in EC.
DYLAN THOMAS: So again,
just to reiterate
on sort of this new
publishing workflow,
there's the separation
of concerns, if you like,
just doing what's
appropriate at which stage.
We're not taking
away functionality
with command-line-driven
workflows
that you may already have.
But we're just giving you
a really easy, new way
to accomplish this in a UI.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
We're just decoupling
the publishing function,
moving all publishing
functions to the server, which
is really where they belong.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah.
Great, thanks.
So why don't we move on and
look at the next two items?
The first was alpha
masking, and I
think we're going to revisit
the WMS item, as well.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
So alpha masking
is a feature that folks have
asked for quite some time.
And the use case
is this-- let's say
I have some really
high-resolution imagery
over Mountain View, California.
The rest of my imagery, though,
is not so high resolution.
And in fact, I want to get
that from some other place,
some other database.
So I can now build
my imagery project
to just have the high-resolution
imagery for Mountain View.
In the past, we've asked
that you have a base
layer with worldwide coverage.
That's no longer necessary.
We've removed that restriction.
So as an example, let's go back
to my Fusion interface here.
And if I pull up
my imagery project,
I have an imagery project here
that consisted of just Cuba.
And I chose Cuba
just because it's
an island with some interesting
features along the coastline.
So I had some high-resolution
imagery of just Cuba.
And I included
that in a database
which I've already published.
If I go back here
to my server UI,
I have this BlueMarble
version 13 database,
which is published at
mount point slash cuba.
And I can see that's
already published.
It tells me when I
published it and the size.
So if I go now to EC, and I
connect to my server slash
cuba, you can see here
that the entire globe
is blank except for Cuba.
So this is my high-resolution
imagery just for that region.
So now I want to overlay
this, essentially,
on a base of lower resolution
imagery from another database,
from some other source.
Now, that could be Google,
through kh.google.com,
if you have a license
of Google Earth Pro.
Or it could be another Google
Earth Enterprise database.
So I'm simply going
to say Add Database.
And I happen to have
another internal GEE server
running, which I'm
going to connect
to to pull in imagery for
the rest of the world.
And there you go.
So if I zoom in to
Cuba now, there's
my imagery for Cuba,
overlaid on top
of the imagery of the world.
DYLAN THOMAS: Nice.
And you can see them both.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Now,
the order does matter.
In this case, the imagery
of my secondary database
is being overlaid on top
of my imagery of Cuba.
So usually, I'd want
to switch that, right?
So typically, then I would
connect to the imagery of Cuba.
That database, I would
connect to that second.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: So I
can simply say Disconnect.
So I'd probably want
to first connect
to my database that
has worldwide coverage
and then add the database
that has the imagery of Cuba.
And there you go.
DYLAN THOMAS: So
the alpha masking
is really a pretty
straightforward feature
in terms of the
end-user experience.
It just makes a lot of sense,
it's how you want to see it,
but that's something
that hasn't been possible
at all until [INAUDIBLE].
Great.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
Right, and this
is a feature which, if you
decide you want in 5.0,
you would need to rebuild
your imagery resource.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DYLAN THOMAS: Because I
think the one of the things
our customers are asking at
this point is about the need
to rebuild databases, the need
to make changes to their core
assets.
And you're saying this is one
of those new features that
will require it.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
The bottom line
is you only have to rebuild your
resources and projects if you
want to get some of
these new features.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
Well, let's round it out then
with a closer look at the WMS
feature.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
OK, yeah, that's
a really exciting feature
that folks have asked for,
especially users of
various OpenGIS tools.
I can make a 2D or a 3D
map accessible through WMS,
and all that
involves is enabling
any one of these
globes-- 2D or 3D.
I'll start with 2D, say
this one right here.
I have already published
this, but I just
want to enable WMS on this.
And let me make sure I'm
serving the latest version here.
10/17-- yep, that's today.
OK, so it's already published.
Serve WMS.
And it says, actually, that
target path is already in use.
So maybe I should choose
a new one, like demo2d.
If I wanted to add search
tabs to this database,
I could, too, right here.
DYLAN THOMAS: Your
point here, though,
is that it's very, very simple.
Even if you've got
it serving already,
you can just go back
and add that capability.
It's very simple.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
The publish points are
dynamically created.
It doesn't involve restarting
the server any time
you make a change or
anything like that.
DYLAN THOMAS: So I know
you can do 3D globes, also.
But why don't we
take a look at what
the client experience here?
I think you have an example
of what this feels like.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
Yeah, so this is
a preview of my very simple
2D natural earth map here.
And it doesn't have very many
layers-- some urban areas,
some country borders,
and that's about it.
So now let's confirm that
it's being served via WMS.
So you typically want to launch
whatever your preferred OpenGIS
WMS client might be.
In this case, I'm
going to launch QGIS.
And over here, I
say Add a WMS Layer.
And you specify your
WMS server here.
Make sure the
endpoint's correct.
The one I created was demo2d.
Type that in, /wms.
If it has a username
or password,
you enter that there, too.
And then I say Connect.
So now it's essentially
done a Get Capabilities
request on my WMS
server and seen,
oh, I have three layers
available-- imagery,
urban areas, and
country borders.
So now I can add the desired
layers into my QGIS workspace.
I'm going to add
country borders, then
urban areas, and
then my imagery.
And if you want to reshuffle,
I guess, the rendering order,
you can just move
any of those up.
DYLAN THOMAS: So just
like the alpha masking,
this looks pretty
straightforward stuff.
And in fact, it is.
But being new in 5.0 is
a pretty major feature
and a major new capability
that customers, as you said,
have been asking for
for a very long time.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Exactly.
DYLAN THOMAS: So this is a
pretty exciting one for us.
And this is WMS 1.3,
and I believe 1.1, also.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Correct.
Yeah, we support up to WMS 1.3.
And as I zoom in, you can
start to see the layers.
It might be necessary to
disable some of those.
Let's see-- depending on
what's being rendered on top.
You can see down here in the
lower left the actual WMS
request that's being made.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great.
Well, let me wrap up with one
quick question for you, then.
You're in the Geo
Support team, so you're
the one who gets all
the tough questions
at the end of the day.
Is there anything
about the 5.0 release
that you think is going to
be difficult for customers
or might trip them up at all?
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Not too
much that I would anticipate.
One feature we have
implemented is sort of
gravitated towards
Mercator map projections.
So for 2D maps, we
support Mercator only now.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
OK.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
And that involves
rebuilding your
imagery projects.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh,
OK, but I think
this is something that
we've announced to our Earth
Enterprise customers for
some time now, right?
So this shouldn't-- hopefully
no surprise to anyone.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
That's correct.
DYLAN THOMAS: But
it's just something,
another one of those--
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
Something to be aware of.
DYLAN THOMAS: And I think
you've worked on the integration
guide-- or the upgrade
guide, I should
say-- of this new version.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: In
the upgrade guide,
and there will be some white
papers on possible solutions
that, if you do have a
flat database on migration
strategies, how to
continue to serve
that flat database as
a Mercator, et cetera.
So we'll offer solutions
along those lines.
DYLAN THOMAS:
That's good to know.
Well, Avnish, thanks so much for
taking the time to talk with us
today about the 5.0 release.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
You're welcome.
DYLAN THOMAS: And
we'll see you next time
on "What in the World."
Thank you.